MARK HOFNER: Thanks
everyone for coming today.
For those of you that don't
know me, my name is Mark Hofner.
I work as--
AUDIENCE: Woohoo.
MARK HOFNER: I got one
fan-- as a software engineer
over in the travel
space here in Cambridge.
So I have the honor today
of introducing and hosting
John Werner, who's here
to talk to us today.
John comes from the
Camera Culture group
over at the MIT Media Lab.
And unlike a lot of
Googlers here in Cambridge,
I have only known John
since very recently.
There are several other folks
that have known him for years.
But I met John a month or two
ago at a Rotary Club meeting
where he presented some
similar content to today.
And the one thing that I
was kind of impressed with
was-- ideas and
everything are great.
We hear a lot of
ideas all the time.
But one of the things
that you don't often see
is the energy behind it.
And so I ask that you give
John your undivided attention.
Because the one thing that I
came away from when he spoke
was how inspired I was again,
especially for those of us
who do a lot of volunteer
work or have a passion
for education-based learning.
So without further ado, let
me introduce John Werner.
Please come on up, John,
and welcome to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN WERNER: Great,
thanks, Mark.
So I'm a dad.
And this is my son Matteo.
And Matteo is a curious soul.
And as parents, there are
these moments of crisis.
Am I doing a good job?
My wife and I, we wonder,
should we be doing more?
Are we screwing our kid up?
And when you're a
parent, you think about,
well, what are the things
that influenced you?
So if I want my
son to be curious,
what facilitated my curiosity?
And so I think back to my dad.
He's wearing the
light blue polyester
shorts-- kind of embarrassing,
but not in the '70s.
And so one thing that was
unique in my upbringing
was I would go to
friends' houses,
because both my parents worked.
And my dad would pick me up
at the end of the evening.
And the way we got home
was we would run home.
We didn't take a
bus, a cab, a subway.
We always would run home.
And sometimes we'd cut across
many different neighborhoods.
And as this kid, it was
just fascinating to see
the transitions
in neighborhoods.
This is pre-eBay.
And people would
throw things out.
Like I remember
rolling-- literally
rolling-- a manhole cover home.
Because I said, Dad, that
would be a great table.
And it was.
And it is to this day.
And so I think back
to what facilitated my
looking at the city and
saying, look at all this stuff.
I think those runs-- a big part.
The other thing I noticed
was that as I started
going to this one
friend's house,
Nicky Seaver-- he was
Tom Seaver's cousin--
we would run home a
different way each time.
And I realized that
there's an infinite number
of ways to do something.
And as a six-year-old,
as an eight-year-old,
that was a big aha.
And that may not
always be efficient.
But I think that
kind of shaped me.
For people who know
me, you'll get that.
So when I moved to Boston, kind
of like exploring the city,
I wanted to unleash
that interest,
that sense of that
experience, for young people.
Inner city middle
schoolers we realized
were getting out
of school at 1:30
so the buses could rotate back
to get the elementary school
kids home.
So these sixth, seventh,
and eighth graders
were out on the streets
getting into no good.
And we said, let's
get the best of Boston
to share their passion.
And this is our logo.
And I remember when we
created it, I was thinking,
it's like the streets.
And we're building a better
city by getting volunteers
to share either what they love
at work or share their passion,
because they don't
love their work.
And they bring it to kids.
So we started this like
a week after Netscape.
Some of you weren't even
born when Netscape came out.
But we were sort
of pre-internet.
I remember our first
offices, we were selling air,
and we ran out of
Kinko's for a long time.
But when we got
our first offices,
we didn't even have email.
And then I think we had one
AOL account that a few of us
could use.
But we were pre-internet
when we did this.
And we scaled it.
And we became the Google
of the nonprofit space.
And we'd use our
Rolodexes to find the best
and brightest to teach.
And so we'd have kids learn
physics by holding a mallet
and breaking it while a
guy was on a bed of nails.
I mean, what better
way to learn physics.
And we did this
collaborative stuff.
So you couldn't see
who was leading.
It was like teamwork.
And here's a dad.
This is Yves.
Two years in the
country from Nigeria.
And you may know Yves, because
if you fly through the Delta
terminal in New Jersey
in Newark, he's your guy.
And Yves said to
me, John, thank you.
My twins each take four
of these apprenticeships
from amazing, talented people.
And they have such
interesting things
to talk about at home now.
It made coming to this
country worthwhile.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So I was like, oh wow,
we've got to do better.
We've got to keep delivering
for dads and moms and guardians
like Yves.
So I said, where are the
best and the brightest?
They're at Google.
So we got Alan to teach.
And he taught like six
semesters in a row.
But then I was
getting suspicious.
This engineer, I was
like, wait a second,
does he have any friends?
He's not able to get any
other Googlers to teach.
I'm like, I don't know.
Is he ostracized or
something at work?
So I went to a guy named Steve
Vinter-- very powerful dude.
He's my guardian angel.
I love this guy.
And I said, let's do a meeting.
And Steve was very wise.
He said, do you know 99%
of the revenue at Google
is not from the engineers,
but it's from the ads people?
I think it's now down to 98%.
That's because Steve's been even
more productive the last year.
And he said, let's get the ads
people and the engineer people.
And it was on an anniversary
of around this week
a few years back.
We got 50 people in a room.
And I said to them,
take out your iPhones.
No one moved.
I said, take out your
Android smartphones,
and people pulled it out.
And I said, text your
interest, your passion.
And real time we threw
it up on the screen.
And so you see
there's lock picking.
There's sailing, a
lot of good things.
One of them is volleyball.
And Bob Castle, who's touring
some muckety muck right now
around the Google campus,
he saw volleyball.
And I think he was embarrassed
and didn't even text anything.
But he was like, I'm
passionate about volleyball.
And then for a week
after that meeting,
he was searching for
that volleyball persons.
It's like Cinderella,
but different.
And he taught a bunch of
volleyball apprenticeships.
So maybe that says
something about he
didn't want to bring
his work to the kids,
he wanted to bring his passion.
I don't know, you can
ask him about that.
So here's some of the kids over
the years that built robots.
And Alan had kids save a
person from a burning building.
It's in LEGO.
It's not really
burning, but it was fun.
Here's some of the ads
people teaching marketing,
how to market yourself.
Here's computer stuff.
And look at this picture.
Is the apprentice more
excited, or is the Googler
more excited about
this Chromebook?
What do you think?
That was an early version
of the Chromebook.
Here are the chefs
teaching cooking.
What better way to teach
cooking than have a Google chef
kind of share their passion?
And then there's
Bob and his team.
He finally got into some coding.
He moved on from volleyball.
And we did all these big events.
But one of the best
things about working
at Citizen Schools
for 1,000 weeks
is that I was Steve Vinter's
personal photographer.
And I got to follow him around.
I feel like this
is like the Beatles
when they were just coming out.
I took pictures of him with
students and talking to people.
And I got pictures of his
wife and his daughter.
And he was just great.
And so I want to thank Steve
Vinter for this opportunity.
Steve, are you in the room?
STEVE VINTER: No, I'm not.
JOHN WERNER: Yeah, OK, could
you just stand and bow?
I just want to acknowledge you.
Can you stand?
Yeah, so this is a great leader.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, so a guy who took
this outpost, which
was like half a person,
to now you're like 1,200
strong and have like the 70
plus offices around the world.
My bed is your number three.
And Mountain View
better watch out
because of the creativity
that comes here.
And a lot of it has to
do with your leadership.
And congratulations.
And the world is a better
place because of that.
So the other thing about
working at Citizen Schools
was I got to go to
this conference.
It's called the FRED Conference.
That's a joke.
If it was FRED--
no, it's called TED.
And TED is awesome.
And it's like 31
years old today.
Richard Saul Wurman
started it in '84.
And it's Technology
Entertainment Design.
It was about doing a soiree
not that much bigger than this
in the early days where
interdisciplinary talks would
take place.
And you get creative people.
I see Mr. [? Wren ?] presented,
one of your Googlers,
at our event.
You get people like that
kind of sharing ideas.
And in the early days,
these were 18 minute talks.
And that was a short format.
And Chris Anderson
bought the event.
He had published "Business 2.0."
He sold it on paper.
He was rich.
It was before one
of those bubbles.
And he flipped TED
into a nonprofit.
And he said, let's take these
short videos, these 18 minute
videos, and get them on TV.
And I have this
image of him going
to like all the different
networks or whatever.
And they all said, no.
No one's going to want this.
This is like a bran muffin.
Who wants this stuff?
And like in "Pretty
Woman," big mistake.
Because what he did was he
went to this little-known thing
in 2006 called
YouTube, and he started
putting these things online.
And today, three billion people
have watched just 2,000 talks.
And it's the third most
respected media property
online.
I see the publisher,
former publisher
for "The Globe," who did a
heck of a job leading that
at a time when the
industry was changing.
And boy, wouldn't you wish
you had those kind of numbers
back when you were doing that?
So TED is just killing it.
And in 2006, Chris said,
I want to put the talks
online for free.
And everyone said,
no, don't do it.
Everyone-- and I've talked
to him about this-- said,
that's stupid.
No one will come to
our conferences, which
are ridiculously expensive.
You could put a down payment
on a house or two houses
for how much it costs to
go to these conferences.
So in 2009, Chris had another
idea that everyone on his team
said, no, this is crazy.
He said, let's
give away licenses
so people can self-organize
and show my video.
He was a marketer.
He thought this was a
way to move his product.
What he didn't
realize was people
were hungry to curate
interesting speakers
like Barmak or
Rohan or Albert, who
are all speakers in the past,
and that there was a big desire
for this kind of content.
So I've been to 10 of
these TED conferences.
They fill up in 15 minutes
a year ahead of time.
I remember the first
one I want to I
was in between a former governor
of Colorado, who you would
recognize, and Jeff Bezos.
And I got sent
something saying, you've
been accepted for next year.
Are you ready to pay the $8,500?
And I'm like, I haven't
even experienced this year.
How do I know if I want
to pay for next year?
And yeah, so how many
places can kind of do that?
But TED's a pretty
special place.
And it's harder to get
into than the Oscars,
and a lot of interesting
conversations happen here.
And I would go here and
talk about Citizen Schools.
I'd talk about
democratizing learning
and how this Citizen Schools
idea was one of the top 10
ideas 100 years from now
that'll kind of change
the vector of society.
And I would talk to people who
invented the personal computer,
or Sergey and Larry.
And you guys know
who those people are.
And it was just awesome.
But one challenge-- I would
come home from this week away,
and I'd see my kids--
Javie, Lucia, Matteo.
And I synced this
picture from when
I came back from the first one.
And I'd have all this
interesting stuff
I'd want to share with my kids.
And my kids would say, Daddy,
are you part of a cult?
Why do you leave us?
Do you love us?
And it got me thinking, how
can we bring the best of TED
into our own zip codes, and how
can we make it family friendly?
I care a lot about my kids.
A lot of you care about
the next generation.
So a few of us incorporated.
And I see Bruce, one of
our board members here.
And I don't know if
you know, but when
Chris Anderson, who grew up
the son of a missionary doctor,
when he bought TED,
he added a tagline--
"Ideas worth spreading."
And I think that's a good line.
But I said, let's go a power up.
Let's do, "Ideas in action."
And this logo is,
let's 10x those ideas.
Let's 10x the community.
And let's not just sit
in auditoriums like this.
Let's get out in the community.
So I don't know if
you see that arrow.
But it's subtle.
You may not see it.
You've got to stare,
and you'll see it.
But say, let's get
in the community.
And so this is my kids' school.
And a lot of these TEDxes--
I don't know if you know.
There are 13,000
TEDx licenses today.
Every day there are like 50
TEDxes around the planet.
Of the 13,000, a lot
of them are focused
on getting the biggest
and fanciest venue.
The Sydney Opera House
is one, Carnegie Hall.
And a big portion of the budgets
for these events goes for that.
And I'm notoriously cheap.
And I didn't want
to spend any money.
I thought I could get
everything in kinded.
So I went to the
school district.
I said, hey, I've got this idea.
Like Warren Buffett says,
invest in what you know.
And I live two blocks
from this building.
This is my kids' school.
Graham Gund designed
it, beautiful school.
It's right behind the Audi
dealership right off Route 9
near the reservoir,
27% low income kids,
a lot of children
of power brokers
also here from the Boston area.
And I said to the school,
hey, can I get the building?
And they said, sure.
And so that's when I
was off to the races.
And the auditorium
holds 290 people.
So it's a little auditorium.
And I made the event free.
And tons of people signed up.
We had 2,700 people
at our last event.
And I said to the people,
it's a free event.
But if you come,
you've got to spread
the ideas that are on stage.
So if our illustrious speakers
have something worth saying,
or if you combine some of
the ideas into something,
you've got to get it out there.
And I said, let's try
to hit 2 million views
in our first year.
And everyone said,
can't be done.
I said, let's hit 10 million
views in our second year.
People said, can't be done.
We had 10,000 soda cans-- there
was a big debate whether they
should be in school-- as a
backdrop as a metaphor to say,
we're trying to hit 10,000.
Last year, we said,
let's do 25 million.
We hit all those marks.
We're, I would say,
a super majority.
99% of the other 13,000
TEDxes have no idea
how many views they've gotten.
We gamified our event and
said, let's get these ideas
out there.
So that's the red dot
where our event happened.
And this was one
of our speakers.
You may know Esther.
Google was founded
in her garage.
And her daughters all
watched the simulcast.
One of them runs
YouTube right now.
I think she's doing
a pretty good job.
And we went to town.
But in addition to having the
one day-- and it's actually
a two day-- event,
we said, let's have
the speakers create field
trips throughout the year.
So if someone in the audience
hears something that they like,
they can go on and
meet that person.
And let's do it
throughout the year,
maybe at lunchtime,
maybe on the weekends,
maybe at midnight, maybe
at 2:00 in the morning.
And let's have these field
trips in interesting places.
And let's combine a
bunch of our speakers,
kind of like "Gilligan's
Island" but different,
without being lost
at sea or whatever.
And we said, let's call
these things Adventures.
And we got people
to not just think,
who would be good at presenting
on stage-- Juan Enriquez.
I was with him yesterday,
one of the best presenters.
He's like Leonardo
da Vinci reincarnated
and Indiana Jones
rolled into one.
And I remember
hearing him speak.
And he referenced a
guy named cliff Tabin.
And I know Cliff.
He's a geneticist.
And I was with Cliff a few
weeks after Juan spoke.
And Cliff had no idea
Juan even referenced him.
And I realized, does
even Juan know Cliff?
And I realized, what if Juan
did a field trip with Cliff
in his lab with genetics?
One of our speakers that's
coming here is George Church.
He wants to bring back
the woolly mammoth.
What if you go hang
out with the DNA that's
going to help
facilitate bringing back
the woolly mammoth?
You don't have to push
a button, because there
are all sorts of
moral issues there,
and maybe you don't
want to go there.
But you at least want
to have a conversation.
So now let me give
you a few examples.
We've done 300 of
these Adventures.
And we kind of did a land grab.
We said, let's do nature.
Lets do social issues.
Let's do competitive advantage.
Let's do mythological events
in the history of the city.
So we could kind
of show the range.
Because if we're going
to unleash this and say
to every city, let's
throw the gauntlet down,
you try to do what we
just did-- because that's
what happened with TED Talks.
Nicholas Negroponte
gave the first one.
A few years later, Larry Lessig
gave one that was really good.
People were like,
I can outdo that
in terms of presentation style.
So we said, let's do
a land grab and get
a range of these things.
So here's one.
So '72, there was
a big fire, one
of the worst fires in the
history of the United States,
in Copley Square.
Because there was
a horse flu-- this
was 1872-- horses
couldn't get to the fire.
Because they had to
pull the carriages.
And it's a good thing
they didn't pull.
Because they would
have realized the hoses
didn't fit into the hydrants.
It was like an
Apollo 13 problem.
So they couldn't
even get the water
if they had been able to
get the carriages there.
As a result, in 12 hour,
776 buildings burned down.
And Copley was just decimated.
And out of that, HH Richardson
built Trinity Church,
which is considered one
of the top 10 buildings
in North America.
It was a beautiful building.
And because this is a mud flat,
they had to take 500 trees,
make them into like
telephone poles.
And there are 500
trees under there
to make sure it doesn't sink.
And so our Adventure
was understanding
how that building got
built and its relationship
to another amazing building.
And IM Pei built this building.
He was supposed to build it--
Prudential had just been built,
John Hancock, which
is local, Prudential,
which is from New
Jersey-- was kind of
insulted that they
built a big building.
So they said, we've got to
have a really big building.
Harry Cobb ended up building it.
And they built this long
building, tall building,
that reflects the area.
And there are all these metal
pylons that stop microbes
from swishing around.
And microbes started to
eat at the Trinity Church.
So we did an Adventure
where we learned
the relationship between
these two iconic buildings.
And we did a dirty tour
under both of them.
And we went to the top floor,
and we met the engineers
that had to fix the problem.
This is one of those kind of
epic events that, oh my god,
I can't believe that happened.
In 1976, every window had to be
replaced in the John Hancock.
I mean, is that an
insurance problem
for an insurance company?
It was a math problem.
It was kind of like the
Hubble Space Station.
They screwed up on the mirror.
The windows were popping out.
They were literally falling.
And there was a moment in time
when this building was just
covered with plywood.
How many of you
did not know that?
OK, so now you know it.
Now you feel smart,
and you're going
to tell your friends
at lunch today.
And how many events are like
that in a city's history,
that you could create a
spotlight that people are like,
wow, this is interesting?
This guy hates robots.
But he built this spider.
He thinks the way
to go is not robots
that are going to
take over the world--
and Albert is going
to talk about reading
a book without opening it.
And you can have a day
when robots go into space
and read books
without opening them,
and then become really smart.
That could be scary,
or it could be good.
But this guy believes
in ectoskeletons.
And so we got to
hang out with him.
He created an eight-legged
spider ectoskeleton that
goes like 4 feet per second.
And we also curated
interesting people.
One of the producers for
"60 Minutes" is in the room.
And if you want to
understand robots,
you want to understand
ectoskeletons,
the difference,
you want to understand
where this could go,
this was a good
Adventure for you.
So anyone heard of Project Loon?
OK, it's one of those
big frickin' ideas.
And it's an MIT Media Lab
guy who came up with it.
And now he's like one
of the leaders at XPRIZE
or at Google X. And I was
at Google X not so long
ago talking to some
people about it.
It's a fascinating
idea-- created a wing,
perpetual, going
around the Earth,
put solar panels on it,
bring internet to places
that don't have internet.
So we said, let's teach
kids about a wing that
could be up perpetually.
So we taught kids how to
fold a little piece of paper.
And if you take a cardboard
and walk behind it,
you can keep it up perpetually.
And we got 70 kids in
an elementary school
to get those gliders up.
And we had 70 of
these up for an hour.
And the kids felt so proud.
And we talked about what
this could mean for Africa
and getting internet there.
And we talked about
if any of them
would like to work
on this project.
And we talked about how
this related to the math
that they had no
idea what relevance
it had to do with anything.
These were little kids, and it
was sort of a loaded question.
But they admitted that
they didn't get it.
Now, they were like, yes.
And this is a few years later.
I still see these kids.
They give me high fives.
I can't wait to work
on Project Loon.
I didn't tell them it's hard to
get into Google X and whatever.
But that's a whole
another thing.
Oh, by the way, have
you heard an Adventure
that you might want
to go on so far?
Have you heard an
Adventure that you
might want to invite people to?
Because part of the idea here
is that you can create these,
or you can invite people, or
you can help document them.
So Carl is a rocket scientist.
And he was obsessed
with rocketry.
And one day he was
reading regulations.
I don't know if
that's what you do.
But he realized the regulations
for what defines a car changed.
And he realized there was a
big opportunity, that if you
have a little plane,
and there's bad
whether, it's a pain
in the butt to fly.
Because you've got to wait.
But he said, what if
that plane could fold up,
and you could drive
it to another airport
where there isn't bad weather?
And the other thing about
having a small plane
is it's expensive.
You've got to rent the hangar.
What if you could fold it up,
and it was the size of an SUV?
And a lot of you
Googlers are like, yeah,
that's what I'm going
to do with my bonus.
So this is Terrafugia,
the flying car at Woburn.
This is a local innovation.
And so we signed NDAs.
Little kids signed NDAs.
They didn't even
know what an NDA was.
And the day before
Oshkosh-- now,
you may not know
what Oshkosh is.
But Oshkosh is the biggest
air show in the world.
The day before Oshkosh, we
went in to their factory.
And we saw their
new prototype where
the propeller was moved from the
back to the front of the plane.
We saw how they worked.
It was like being
at Apple the day
before the first
iPhone came out.
So it's not only where you
go, but the timing of it.
Here's another Adventure.
I found a Black Hawk
helicopter pilot
who was just being
chartered to fly
CO types to get to the
airport so they felt like COs.
And I said to him, why don't
you take the helicopter apart
and put it back together?
And why don't you fly
over the watershed
and get a few people to
think about how everything's
connected?
There's a book,
"10x" or something,
"10 Up," where you see, you
get further and further.
But how many people
really get to go up?
So we had a kid
and a dad learning.
And I remember that
flight went over--
I said, go over that place
where they recycle cans.
Because we know you've got
to put the recycle thing
in the recycling.
But how do you know that
really gets recycled?
Maybe the joke's on us.
Maybe it doesn't get recycled.
But if you actually
see the place,
maybe it'll make you think
differently about it.
And if you see the
place, maybe you'll
think of a way to
make it better.
Maybe this is kind of
inefficient from up above.
You say, hey, I've got an idea.
And we've done this a few times.
And the reality is how
many people can you really
get on the helicopter?
Because it's finite.
But if you create an interesting
video that goes viral,
suddenly people will
get this vicariously
through other people
experiencing it.
I'm going to come back to that.
So we went to a jail.
We had someone talking about
meditating with inmates.
And you're like, I'm not
going to commit a crime.
I'm not going to
be found in jail.
You're not going
to tune that in.
But if you go to a jail, and
you meditate with inmates,
it suddenly becomes real.
And I remember
this date vividly.
I bet the people
we brought on this,
this is going to be a life
changing event for them.
We had Omar Wasow, who's Oprah
Winfrey's technology advisor,
come, founded BlackPlanet.
He was doing his PhD at the
time on incarceration rates
for African Americans
in the '70s.
And it changed his whole
orientation that day
from what he was
doing his PhD on.
We had someone come who had
not talk to their brother in 18
year since he had
been locked up,
because they so resented him.
And I think this was an
eye-opening experience.
And I've since learned she
reached out to her brother.
We had someone who
secretly said to me, hey,
I'm thinking of
committing a crime,
and I want to know
what's at stake here.
And I didn't advertise
that at the time.
But that's kind of interesting.
Yeah, people are looking
like, oh, is it that person?
We also heard from the inmates.
And I think this was
an incredibly nurturing
experience.
Because they got to
tell their story.
And many of these guys were
in there multiple times.
And you're like, what the what?
You come back?
And we understood how
it led to coming back.
And if you look
at the statistics,
twice the number of people
of color are coming back.
And why is that?
And that should make you angry.
And you should be aware of that.
And with all the stuff going
on with Ferguson and so on,
this is a insight into
some of that stuff.
The thing is what
goes on in jail,
and understanding how
they use their time,
can be very informative
in how to help these folks
kind of transition
back into society.
Our society locks
up a lot of people.
So this is worth thinking
about Adventures.
And how we can put a
spotlight on social issues
can be really interesting.
Environment-- so we did
this one because lobsters
are really cheap.
And people are like, yes,
I can get cheap lobsters.
But there's an
unintended consequence.
If lobsters are
cheap, why is that?
It's because there are too many.
Why is that?
What does that have to
do with climate change?
So we said, let's go
lobster boat fishing.
That's a New England thing.
Maybe in Wisconsin it's not
so much about the lobster.
But they have other equivalents.
And so this is an example.
Highlight something
special in your region.
And [? Asham ?], who's over
here, wrote about that.
It went viral on
some blog in India.
I think that was his first
time he was blogging in India.
Who's been to the
star, our star?
Anyone?
So we said, let's go to
a star on planet Earth.
This is a plasma lab
that talked about energy.
This was fascinating.
And I had heard
about this lab at MIT
where people said,
oh, it's boring.
Don't go there.
But when we brought-- I had
100 people sign up for this.
And I said, I only want
40 to go in at a time.
We did three tours.
And the people said
it was just riveting.
And I think when you bring
a diverse group of people
who ask interesting questions,
it takes the folks leading
the tours, leading the
experience, up a notch.
So there's another
physics here that you
can make things that are boring
interesting and important.
This is going to
Dean Kamen's lab.
This was on the Colbert
show a few days earlier.
There's a Stirling engine
bicycle, motorcycle, which
you're not supposed to see.
That's why there's
only half of it.
So don't tell anyone you
see it if you see it.
We went to Dean Kamen's
lab when he wasn't there.
Dean Kamen's amazing.
He's one of the
most inspiring guys.
But if you want to
meet the machinist that
built the Segway, you want to
meet the machinist that built
Luke's arm-- we had
to sign another NDA,
two NDAs in one week here-- you
want to go to the front line.
And at a time when we outsource
China, Taiwan, to build stuff,
we said, let's go to a glass
blowing factory in Roxbury.
How many have been
to Roxbury this week?
That's like a few blocks
from here, less than 2 miles.
But how often are
you going in there?
Here's another Adventure.
So a bunch of
scientists discovered
the planet was much
older than they thought
it was on this plugged volcano.
This is a very famous place.
In the history of
scientific milestones,
this is one of them.
Because they looked
at the ground
and looked at the rocks and the
tectonics and all this stuff
and said, wait a second.
We are so frickin' wrong.
And we climbed this
mountain with Jodie Foster.
And we talked to her about, what
was it like making "Contact"?
And if you think the People's
Choice Awards was bizarre
when she got up and
spoke, this was amazing.
I mean that in total respectful.
I love Jodie Foster.
She's awesome.
So this is a guy from
Sweden who led an Adventure.
And he talked about this
little prize for 22 years
he ran-- the Nobel Prize.
For medicine, for chemistry--
he did three of them.
I can't remember the
third one, not the peace
and the economics.
It turns out the economics
is really a pay-off.
It's like he didn't even
consider it a Nobel Prize.
But how many of you
would like to hear
from the guy that ran the
process of who shouldn't
have gotten the prize?
Or what happened to
the people who got
the prize as a result of it?
Because he's tracked that stuff.
Or who should have gotten
it who didn't get it?
And this guy has so
much knowledge on that.
This is my last Adventure
I'm going to share.
And then I want to
pose some ideas.
And you guys are clever.
I want to get you guys to
wrap your heads around-- this
is Peter.
His office is in James
Watson's old office.
James Watson-- DNA,
articulated it.
Didn't discover it--
it was there before.
But he realized it was there.
So Peter goes in Alvin.
That's not Alvin
and the Chipmunks.
He goes in that submarine that
scrubs the bottom of the ocean.
And he's probably been in
it more times than most.
And he's looking at microbes.
And I would bet
if anyone's going
to have a big impact on global
change of the people I've met,
he's probably one of the most
important people, a biologist.
And he brings back creatures
and puts them in jars.
And we brought 50 people
to meet his creatures.
And this creature-- I was
really struck by this one.
There's a movie
called "Finding Nemo."
And there's a creature
depicted in that movie
only because Peter found it
on the bottom of the ocean.
If it wasn't for Peter finding
it, you would not know.
I don't know if that's one
of the most important things
in society.
But in terms of commercial
celebrity stuff,
I feel like that's up there.
So there's this underground
lair, think bat cave,
at Harvard, where the physics
department, think Cold War,
used to do stuff.
But they don't do it anymore.
So Peter re-transformed that
into his biological laboratory.
And we brought a bunch of
families, a bunch of kids,
down there to see how it's done.
And there's this one little girl
who felt and held this $45,000
submarine.
And I remember she
said to me, I think
I want to be a marine biologist.
Before that night,
she didn't even
know what a marine
biologist was, even
though she knew "Finding Nemo."
And the way Tom Brady
is the one quarterback,
and you don't have
other quarterbacks--
there may be a situation where
Julian Edelman gets the ball
or whatever.
But it's rare for other
players to be the quarterback.
I coached lacrosse
for seven years.
I've got a lot of
stories on that.
But that's for another day.
In lacrosse, whenever
someone gets the ball,
they're directing.
In American soccer, football,
American football-- same thing.
So when you bring a diverse
group of people together,
you can also have the
kid become the Tom Brady,
become the leader in a
decentralized kind of setting.
This isn't a ramen noodles thing
that we just started yesterday
because we got a hypotheses.
We've been at this
for five years.
And we've had 300 Adventures,
10,000 people go on them.
And we've created
a bunch of content.
And without even trying,
we've hit 25 million views.
That's nothing to sneeze at.
Those are some real numbers.
And I looked at our
Google Analytics.
Thank you for
tracking this stuff.
All but six countries
have visited our website.
And is this is just
the last few months.
And so people are
interested in what we're
doing around these Adventures.
So we created a toolkit.
And I sent it out.
And I got back this version.
And I don't think there was a
Translation Google button that
turned it into Chinese.
But someone laid
it out in Chinese.
Thank you.
I don't know who that was.
So these Adventures,
there's some guidelines.
And it's in the toolkit.
You want someone
to invite people.
Some people have friends.
Bring them.
You want someone to be the Ryan
Seacrest, the kind of host.
In exchange for coming
to these events,
we say, give a fun fact.
And the Ryan Seacrest, instead
of reading a whole bio,
kind of is the broker
between the people presenting
and the audience.
We also want people to use their
digital devices to document it.
And we want people to edit it.
So instead of just putting
what you've documented online,
like, hey, I just had
toast, have someone
just really think about
how to tell that story.
And this is some
of our examples.
We had people create content.
We had agency people
that feel like they're
at the bottom of the food chain
trying to sell Huggies toilet
paper kind of make these
documents for these big ideas.
We've had a grandma
do watercolors.
So this is the beginning
of empowering people.
We had a comedian make
fun of what we were doing.
He was really funny,
John Stewart era.
We also said, if we're really
going to do this beyond our zip
codes in Boston, and
we want to go global,
let's invite 100 people.
And again, I'm cheap.
And I said, look,
you've got to fly here.
We'll put you up.
I didn't tell them it was
a hostel, a youth hostel.
And last year, for that
particular weekend,
we had these people fly.
And these are some of the most
social savvy media people.
These are people Google
you want to hire.
And they came.
And they loved the training.
A lot of different
countries represented here--
on the bottom, you have
three from Trinidad,
three from China,
three from Costa Rica.
And the other picture,
that's six continents
represented who came to learn
about how to do Adventures.
So everyone recognizes this guy.
This is a tour guide standing
in front of the bus saying,
on your left is Martha Stewart,
or on your right, that's
Martha Washington.
In the hierarchy of jobs,
that's probably not very high.
And tech support used
to be the same way.
But Apple's changed that
with the Genius Bar.
What if Adventures we created
a kind of whole new cool role
in society?
We've had a lot of third
party kind of validate
what we're doing as interesting.
Chris Anderson that runs
TED at the Aspen Institute
said, this is awesome.
Forbes kind of did
a whole article
on us saying we're
the future of TED.
So I was at Citizen Schools
for 19 years, loved it.
We're the Google of
the nonprofit space.
Larry Summers is our board
chair, former secretary
of treasury and former
Harvard president,
$42 million nonprofit.
I helped hire 2,000 people.
But we were
pre-internet, really.
We weren't using video.
We weren't using social
media to tell our story
to perpetuate what
we were doing.
And I feel like this
idea of Adventures
is harnessing those things.
So now I'm at MIT.
Part of what I'm
doing is helping
to create low cost
medical solutions
and using innovative spaces
in Hyderabad and Mumbai
to get the best talent
to kind of solve problems
very similar to Adventures.
We're also thinking about
tier two cities were
more people on the planet live.
How can you use data
to solve problems?
We want to scale that.
But the last few years,
I've been thinking about,
where are we?
And these are some slides
to really listen to.
So kind of lean in here.
So this is Poland.
This is 1904.
And this is a post card.
And notice there's some
space on the bottom.
And that's not a typo.
In the early years
of post cards,
they often left spaces on the
bottom so someone could say,
I am here.
This is a selfie before digital.
So now people are
going like this.
They're trying to
get more people.
You even have these poles.
You see the tourists in front
of the MIT Dome doing this.
But that's still a
two dimensional thing.
Where are selfies going to go?
What if everyone uses a
smartphone and uses video,
adds the z-axis, time?
And instead of having all
these different selfies,
that stuff gets aggregated.
So let me introduce you to
a guy who learned online.
This is a guy who grew
up in rural Wisconsin.
He had very few friends.
And one day, he locked
himself in a closet and video
taped himself dancing.
He was pretty bad.
And he looked on
YouTube at the comments.
And he got better.
And he looked at
other people dancing.
And now he's considered
the top popper.
I don't even know what that is.
But he, through
self-directed learning,
learned how to be
a great dancer.
And I heard Eric Schmidt--
who's actually at MIT right now,
today.
Eric Schmidt, at the 25th
anniversary of the MIT Media
Lab, said, hey, this equalizing
content for all to learn
in rural places is awesome.
So this guy ended up
paying for med school.
And now he's at
UCLA because he used
asynchronous learning,
self-directed interest,
to learn.
So this is an old guy.
And a lot of people
saw him as a cripple.
Because he had a stroke
and couldn't walk.
But he got around the college
I went to in this tricycle.
And most people didn't even
spend any time talking to him.
But I talked to him.
And this guy was fascinating.
This guy is that
guy Jeffrey but 93.
And as people live longer,
encouraging lifelong learning,
encouraging kind of bringing
intragenerations together
is something we can facilitate
through these Adventures.
So Google, you're responsible
for a lot of cat videos.
And I don't know if you're proud
of that, if you laugh at that.
But what if for every cat video
there were Adventure videos?
And what if this Adventure
idea went fractal?
So Wikipedia has a
lot of contributors.
And I actually think
this chart is incorrect.
Because with AI, there's
going to be a lot more content
generated.
And this is our first speaker
years ago, Sunita Williams.
And there's an interesting
story about her.
My son in first grade
came to me and said,
Daddy, Daddy, Daddy,
we're learning about NASA.
Don't you know three astronauts?
Could we get one of them
to come and visit and talk?
And I said, probably not.
But I said I could
Skype or Google
Hangout-- I don't know if you
know there's Google Hangout.
I could Google Hangout
one of them into the room.
And so I went to the teacher.
This teacher did a
great job teaching
reading and writing and
keeping my son's class safe.
And the teacher said, no.
And I'm like, what?
You don't want an
astronaut to be in class?
And I unpacked
that a little bit.
And I realized she wasn't
being judged on that.
She didn't know how the
kids evaluated on it.
She didn't know how
the kids would act.
SUNITA WILLIAMS:
I'm Suni Williams.
And I'm currently on the
International Space Station.
Me and my crew mates have been
here for the last four months
truly living a dream,
putting ideas into action.
JOHN WERNER: So that's
the talk that didn't
happen at my kid's school.
But what that made
me realize is there's
people with social capital.
Steve Vinter has
ridiculous social capital.
People walk around
the Earth for him.
You can't just plug that
social capital into schools
as schools exist-- Columbine,
other safety issues.
But if we created a mechanism
to kind of connect people.
So the top 2% or 10%
of Wikipedia generators
do most of the generation.
What if we unleashed content
generation of these Adventures
to the masses, and all
that content went out
on different social avenues?
Now right now, if you want
to go to the Super Bowl,
it's pretty expensive.
You have to pay a lot of money.
But what if we
disrupted tickets,
and suddenly every
institution-- art houses,
historic places-- set aside a
certain percentage of tickets,
because they wanted to curate
a more interesting audience
through Adventures than they
thought they could get randomly
by people buying tickets?
And if they got a little bit
of access, some social media,
some new selfies were
created that would
be more valuable than
nickel and diming
people for the $1,200 per
ticket, that's a big idea.
The other thing is
I was at Google I/O.
And I took five of these.
I really like your Oculus Rift.
There's a lot of content that
needs to be generated for VR.
And there are
going to be drones.
And Google Street
View, you're going
to have cars driving around.
But what if you created
a format, a standard,
through these Adventures,
if you went fractal,
and tens and
thousands and millions
and kajillions and
kabillions of content
was generated that
suddenly could
become the future of
the VR experience?
So I think we can flip some
traditional institutions--
education, journalism.
At a time when we need
journalism more than ever,
editorializing how
complicated life is-- cloning,
climate change, all these
things-- the business model
dropped out.
Talk to Chris.
Every quarter, he had to
let go of half his staff.
Because people
aren't buying ads.
Because Google,
you're killing it.
But what if we created
these Adventures
as a new form of journalism
or education or conferences?
So "Time" magazine
put this out there.
This isn't a secret.
If you map out the
shareable economy,
there are a lot
of opportunities.
And I don't think experiences
is on there in the way
that we've conceived Adventures.
There's an opportunity
here, blue sky.
So this is my second
to last slide.
So where to go from
here-- so ideas in action,
we have a license
to do TEDx events.
And November 3 is
a working date.
But in this room,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to do
TEDx Beacon Street
Salon first week of November.
And the reason I want to
do it is I'm betting you
guys are not going to come
across the street to MIT.
But if we bring interesting
speakers here and videotape
them and say, we want to create
Adventures on all of them
throughout the year, that
we can get a bunch of you
to help with that.
Who thinks that's kind
of an interesting idea?
That doesn't mean you've signed
up, even though-- Sean, take
a picture of that.
Who thinks this is
an interesting idea?
OK, that doesn't mean you've
signed in a court of law
that you're involved.
But if we do a few
Adventures here,
kind of like how Facebook
went viral through Ivy League
and Myspace didn't, we can bring
some legitimacy to this idea.
We also have two weeks before
Thanksgiving our big event
at the Lincoln School if you
want to be involved with that.
We have 90 speakers.
They're all online.
Their bios are there.
TED says they're as good
if not a little bit better
than theirs.
They didn't say that.
But they said it's
as good, not better.
In March, on St. Patrick's Day,
at the Heinz Convention Center
in the Weston, we're teaming
up with some surgeons.
We're going to do TEDx
Beacon Street Surgery.
And we're excited about that.
And in April, we're
partnering with Spartan Races.
And on the 100th anniversary
of MIT, we have TEDx MIT.
So I don't really care
about conferences.
What I care about is setting
in motion Adventures.
And if we can kill it in
Boston and kill it in New York,
we're going to get attention.
And I had a guy get on
a plane three weeks ago,
the chief revenue
officer from Zillow.
And he said, John, this is
one of the best platforms
I've ever heard.
You've gotta take
it to the next level
to get the Seattle mafia
involvement, and we're ready.
I don't think it's a real
mafia, but I don't know.
Whatever, that was a joke.
So can you laugh?
Because we're videotaping.
All right, so that's my talk.
And I haven't totally
figured this out.
But there are a lot of people
who are awesome on this team.
I took seven classes at
Harvard Business School
trying to learn how to lead.
And I'm not using
anything I learned
in any of those classes.
So I'd probably fail
if I was submitting
how we're doing this.
We've got a virtual
organization.
No one is salaried.
And we want to take
this to the next level.
And because I love
Steve Vinter, and he's
been like an inspiration
every day of my life,
I said, Steve, let
me help you out.
I want you to get
that promotion.
So I said I'll bring
more of our stuff here.
I know you're upset about
Google Health and whatever.
So Steve, I'm there for you, OK?
I'm here for you.
All right, who found
this interesting?
Who found this better
than they thought it was
going to be when they came in?
OK, I'm not going to ask if
it was worse or the same.
All right, I want to
hear five things that you
learned that you didn't know.
Get to the mic and say it.
This isn't question time.
Just say something that's
an aha, an epiphany.
It doesn't have to be profound.
We'll cut it out in the post
video unless you're voyeuristic
and you want that
stuff out there.
Go.
It can be anyone in the room.
Go-- mics.
Hurry up.
AUDIENCE: OK, I didn't know
about the Copley Square thingy.
Because I'm not a Boston person.
I didn't know that IM Pei
had built the other building
next door.
JOHN WERNER: Harry
Cobb did, actually.
He was a protege for IM Pei.
If you went on the
Adventure, you'd know.
AUDIENCE: I didn't know you
had had 25 million hits.
Because when I did it,
I think we were at 10.
So that's three.
I didn't know you had
done that many Adventures.
Because I think I was
part of one, so only one
out of the whole thing.
And I didn't know about
all your different things.
I knew about the
Lincoln School venue.
But I didn't know
about the other one.
So that's five.
JOHN WERNER: Great,
so I was looking
for five different ones.
But that was fine.
Let's give her a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So four other
people kind of just
play back something interesting.
Because just because
I said it, there
may be something that stuck out
in your mind, and that'll help
validate that this
was interesting.
So someone else go.
AUDIENCE: So I'd been
talking to John a little bit
previously about this.
But your talk today
reinvigorated this,
that the experience
is one aspect of this.
But what's amazing, especially
with the shareable economy,
is that piece of content
that comes out of it
and how valuable certain
people treat that.
And so I think
what's particularly
interesting about
the idea is that bit,
whether it's something
that's not just a selfie.
It's something more, kind of
a community selfie almost,
one that would be
stitched together somehow.
So I think that's
the bit of the idea
that I'm particularly
intrigued by, especially
from a platform perspective or
something, how that would work
and stuff.
JOHN WERNER: And with
exponential change,
Moore's law, the
technology is going
to be there to do amazing
things, AI creating content.
And it's about us thinking
about how to use our time.
And Google, you do 10% time.
Or you do interesting
things with time.
You have more employees.
Like when I go to Pixar, I feel
like everyone has two jobs.
You guys, I feel like you have
two people for every job here.
I don't mean that in a bad way.
But you value time.
And I think we can change how
people see time in society
by getting this right.
AUDIENCE: Mine is less
about what I learned.
It's actually a
question for you.
JOHN WERNER: Bring it on.
AUDIENCE: So you
went to I/O. Did
you connect with
the Expeditions team
that we have here at Google?
Because a lot of what you talked
about reminded me of the work
that they're doing
with Google Cardboard.
For people who didn't
see the announcement,
they're trying to bring
adventures to the classroom
where a school bus can't go.
So they're using
Google Cardboard
to bring like videos
from Paris or China.
And it allows kids
to investigate
a project or an area
that they might otherwise
never get to see.
So I'm wondering how you might
be collaborating with them.
Because I could
see that obviously
leads really well into making a
platform into schools directly
for what you guys are doing.
JOHN WERNER: So Matteo, my
youngest, for some reason
we're talking about England.
I'm like, do you
know where that is?
He's like, yeah, it's in Paris.
And I think if you could
experience these things,
you would know there's a
difference between England
and Paris.
And I've talked to
senior people at Google,
like these very
senior people, who
really want to help
someone in bed or someone
who can't walk get
access to information.
And schools is
one of the places.
And you guys are great at
making information accessible.
So at Google I/O, I
talked to a lot of people.
I was with Megan Smith,
so I felt like a pinball.
I was bouncing off walls.
She's awesome.
But I'm now ready to kind
of go to the next level
to say, who should
we collaborate with?
And I don't want this to become
a one percenter type thing
that only the super rich do.
I mean, you have a
Googler that got 30 people
to spend two years
to figure out how
to make a space suit that he
could drop from Earth, right?
Not everyone can do that.
And I want this to be something
that everyone can do and can
bring diverse people together.
And finding the
right partnerships
like that one I think is
very strategic at this point.
So I'd love your help on that
if you're part of that team.
All right, let's get
three more things.
And then you can do questions.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
didn't realize that any
of the ideas that you
hear about in TED or TEDx
actually went on
further than that.
I thought, like
you said earlier,
the motto is, "Ideas
worth spreading."
So I thought essentially
the ideas spread, and then
the whole goal was
for other people
to continue spreading them,
and hopefully at some point
someone would take action.
But I didn't realize there was
already something doing that.
JOHN WERNER: So a few years
ago, I came back from TED.
And when I met with Chris
Anderson, I sat in his office.
I said, hey, I got this
idea of these field trips.
I said, why don't
you create a budget.
We'll make it another element of
your website, and I'll kill it.
And he said, John, I'm
just juggling too much.
You just have fun with it.
So he said no.
And I'm glad he did.
Because I've been able
to kind of percolate it.
And I think we can get-- of the
12,000 TEDxes, a third of them
to be doing Adventures.
But my goal is
not to stop there.
What if all the Google
GDGers-- how many are there,
Development Group Developers?
I think there's
like-- at I/O, they
were all at I/O. What
if they all did it?
What if the 400,000
IEEErs start doing this?
What if anyone who
is part of a group--
so the TEDx is
just the beginning.
But I want to make
this everything.
All right, Steve.
STEVE VINTER: So could
you be specific about what
the thing is you want
to do at Google next?
Let me just give you my
perspective on some of this.
I think John's done one of
the more creative things that
is going on with TEDx.
And he's trying to take
it to the next level.
And I think it's really
important to do that.
Because it's about
the experience.
And that's what's
really magical.
And what I've been
trying to figure out
is how Google engages with this.
And not in the sense of, oh,
we can have an event here,
but actually trying to do
something more than that.
And the key is actually
first getting involved
and starting somewhere.
And we've already hosted TEDx
Beacon Street a couple times.
But now you're talking about
actually having a bigger event
here.
And so I'd like
people to understand
what that request is.
Because to me, the key
to this whole thing
is taking the next step from
where you currently are.
And the next step requires
people to get involved.
And so I just want to make
it really clear that's
to me what I'm trying to figure
out how to make happen here
at Google apart from
the discussions you
I have all the time
about kind of where
the whole overall
program is going.
So could you be really
explicit about that?
JOHN WERNER: Yeah,
so to be clear,
the first week of
November we're going
to have a few speakers here.
And I want to reverse engineer
who would be great speakers
to lend themselves to
do Adventures and maybe
before the event,
maybe during the event,
maybe in the next
two years after.
And I want the Google
community to be
able to invite people to go
on those-- friends, family,
and a few others.
And I want to create
a new unit of media
from those Adventures that
are worthy of showcasing
what's possible on Adventures.
And when you say it's affiliated
with the Google office,
I want to create a jealousy
in the other Google offices
around the world to say, hey,
if Vinter's team can do it,
we can do it, too.
I also want to think about how
these experiences can scale.
And you guys are about 10x.
So I just put out there,
hey, let's disrupt tickets.
Let's disrupt creating
content for VR.
That's just me thinking the
last week as a force function.
Because I knew I was getting
in front of you guys.
But you guys are clever.
I bet you guys can come up
with a bunch of other ideas.
And as this bounces
around the Google network,
if anyone sees to this
point in the video,
come tell us what
we think we can do.
I also think this runs
counter to the way things are,
and that there are a lot
of interesting trends
that we're harnessing that
we're ahead of the curve.
And that's why the
guy from Zillow
flew out to meet with us.
And I need help complementing.
We got the vision.
We got the creativity.
But we don't have
the operations.
We don't have the platform yet.
So maybe some of you don't
want to do a conference.
But maybe you might want
to help think through,
what does a platform look like?
You guys are experts at that.
The other thing is if you want
to kind of kick the tires, come
to some of our events.
And it's fun.
And a lot of you
care about things.
A lot of you help
support nonprofits.
Maybe we create Adventures
around the things
you care about.
And so that's
something interesting.
Steve, is that specific enough?
STEVE VINTER: Very much so.
JOHN WERNER: OK,
Martha, what do you got?
MARTHA: I didn't know
that there was less
than a handful of countries that
hadn't seen TEDx Beacon Street.
JOHN WERNER: It's less than 10.
I think it's seven.
MARTHA: That's remarkable.
JOHN WERNER: No
bull shit about it,
I want to get those countries.
MARTHA: Well, the
fact that there are--
AUDIENCE: I sent an
email to one of them.
JOHN WERNER: Thank
you, thank you.
MARTHA: 25 million views--
JOHN WERNER: We're actually at
26.2 to be accurate, but yeah.
MARTHA: Well, I think
it's remarkable.
I love that your son inspired
the TEDx Beacon Street
concept of bringing it right
home right to your backyard.
I didn't realize that there
were so many Adventures that
were actually around the globe.
That's very exciting.
And I want to just stress that
now there are 13,000 TEDxes.
But TEDx Beacon Street is really
at the top of its game, right?
So I also just wanted
to share that I'm just
absolutely drunk on the
information and gathering
and the community building.
And I love what you're
doing, so thank you.
JOHN WERNER: So is
there anyone who
wants to ask a question
or state something?
I see Mark.
My guess is he's
bringing us together.
MARK HOFNER: I have two things.
One is an idea.
And the other was
to wrap things up.
But I'm going to put
Charlie Sawyer, who's
in the back of the room here,
on the spot a little bit
as a potential idea for
one of these Adventures.
So Charlie is an amazing figure
who lives and breathes blues.
And if you look
right outside here,
you'll see his phenomenal
photography from
years'-- or decades',
I should probably say--
worth of events
that he's gone to.
And he's actually written
a biography on BB King,
I believe it was, the biography
on BB King, who has just
passed away, unfortunately.
But I think he would
be somebody who
would be one of those
amazing people to enlist.
JOHN WERNER: So get a famous
recording studio, like at WGBH,
and get some jazz
musicians in there.
Then do a petting zoo
with the instruments,
and then take pictures
of the people.
And you share your passion.
And that's the
kind of creativity.
We need people to curate
what you do, where you do it,
when you do it.
Is it at midnight?
Is it at Wally's in the South
End where a lot of good jazz
is?
So yeah, I want to
unlock people like that.
So instead of a
kid saying, oh, I'm
going to go serve food
at a soup kitchen,
what if one day every
single high schooler instead
of community service
said, am I going
to come up with an Adventure,
am I going to lead one,
am I going to document
it or edit it?
And I want to unleash that.
MARK HOFNER: I
want to wrap it up
by saying thank you to
John for coming today.
This was an absolutely
wonderful talk.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN WERNER: And
Jacqueline Winter is here.
If anyone wants to get
involved or has a question
or think I was really
inaccurate on something
and needs to be edited out,
please let Jacqueline know.
She's awesome.
You've been a great audience.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]